there is also a great culture diversity
in Bhutan but I think as a culture as a
whole has been instrumental in
understanding in shaping the
biodiversity ethics why is because the
culture is Buddhist or Hindu and jeiza
especially in Buddhism and in prep ilysm
beliefs there is a huge respect for
nature and that all all things in nature
are living living so you cannot hurt
them and to give you an example in
Bhutan very often you see a road going
through taking a term and avoiding big
rock why because the rock is a habitat
of the local deity and you should not
cut the rock so this is very important
traditionally in Buddha you had forest
which was a boat of local deities you
had pigs you know climbing mountain is
not allowed in beautiful religious
reasons for so there is a huge respect
in a way of the environment and then
Buddhism which respect all living beings
and all so this has been incorporated in
the issue of environment preservation
very easily and really taken easily by
the Bhutanese so that is which are great
at managing their own resource in a
traditional context so this has been one
of the strongest influence of culture in
the ethics of biodiversity
one thing I found very are interesting
in Bhutan compared to the West in
general is that in the West we tend to
keep religion or beliefs let's say
beliefs to the right private sphere of
the family or an institution and but
it's not in the landscape and the
Himalayas and in Bhutan in particular
where as a landscape the landscape is
full of reference to beliefs you cannot
escape beliefs when you walk or when you
drive in buta and this is one strong
point of the culture the culture is
infused in the in the landscape or the
landscape is infused by the culture and
the rituals are not only for the human
beings the ritual which are performed
which you have a extremely wide variety
and even after 30 years I still discover
rituals the rituals are not confined for
human beings the rituals are for human
beings but also the environment because
if the human beings are happy the gods
are happy again
interdependence and when I say God sees
all the local deities and if you anger
local deity by doing something which is
polluting the world dream in Tibetan and
in Zanka you will get immediately or one
month later a retribution in a negative
way which means it's very important for
example if you go to the pasture after
it's been locked for the winter because
a deity don't want people to go up to
the pasture in winter you will have a
retribution the next year the pasture
will not be
as good as the year before because the
data has been angry but at the same time
this is fantastic in environment
management so the culture has really
infused all this environment and it's
not only you when you are doing the
ritual you are doing it also for to plug
it or to please the local deities
playing archery which is a very strong
point of the culture in Bhutan it's a
male oriented culture in that way
archery is very male feature but at the
same time it is to please the local
deities and if the local deities are
pleased with your shout with your and
with your enjoyment at playing archery
they will bring a good harvest
that's why most of the local rituals
include archery the 2008 Constitution in
Bhutan which is a first constitution of
Bhutan was really a watershed in terms
of secularization of the state and in
terms of religious beliefs because the
Constitution said now before Buddhism
was the state religion
now the Constitution says that the king
is a product of all religion and all
religions have to be respected this of
course created a lot of uneasiness among
what we call the mock body the Hmong
body is a state state sponsor of
organization which gather as under its
umbrella all the monks from the top
ecology which are at the base of the
state the state was created in the 17th
century by religious people of the took
back a new pass school Ranger school
which became the monk
and which run the country for two and
half centuries so it has a huge
historical importance and the
Constitution also say that Buddhism gave
its culture and its features to the
Bhutanese State which is absolutely true
but it has become much more inclusive
now so the modern body plays a very
important role nowadays in terms of
spiritual healing and spiritual health
for the country as an institution it
does all the great state rituals and it
has a very strong influence on the way
people think but at the same time and
this is a very interesting point again
which shows how complex is beautiful is
that in order to secure eyes more the
country the religious people are not
allowed to vote in the elections because
there was a fear that they would be too
influential in the result of the
elections so they are not allowed to
vote and there are some critics right
now who are saying that it is not a
human right they are deprived of the
basic human rights because human rights
are well known in Bhutan now and we have
ILCs as translated declaring Universal
Declaration of Human Rights in zonka
which is I think an achievement and
people always talk about their human
rights right now in the last five years
and so the there is a discussion going
on will in the next election which will
take place in five years will this close
in the Constitution be changed or not
and they are very vocal advocate
of the changes that the marks and the
religious people should be allowed to
vote so that shows the complexity of the
issue of Buddha with all its tradition
and its religious past in the modern
world languages in Bhutan there is a
complex issue it's a fascinating issue
and every the Bhutanese are linguist
that's why I do not understand why in
the West people have problems even with
two languages many people in Bhutan say
ninety percent of the population speak I
don't say write or read because some are
not are not written but speak fluently
three to five language including people
in the countryside people who are doing
menial tasks in the government everybody
is a multilingual
it's absolutely awesome I mean I've know
no other word for that so why do they
speak so many languages first of all
they speak their mother tongue which is
neither Danka
which is a natural language or English
which is the official language both
zonka and English are compulsory in
schools they are the languages of in
education and it means that a kid which
is six year old arrived in a primary
school in a remote area of Bhutan and
start learning to alphabet to way of
thinking and two totally unrelated
languages which he doesn't speak of she
doesn't speak at home and at home what
do they speak to call it a mother tongue
is again a gender bias because the
mother might be speaking a language the
father might be speaking another
language and they might communicate in a
third language together that's why I'm
amazed at the linguistic capacity of the
is absolutely amazing so English and
zonka the kids arrive in school and
they're faced some of them of course
picked some cars our first language but
said 20% of the population only and
zonka white uncle was chosen as a
national language is because they felt
they needed to have their own language
in the sixties and they created a
written language so Danka was pokin but
not written and they created this
language which would become Hong Kong
means the language of the zone of the
language of the state and it is related
to Tibetan it's quite different from
Tibetan but it is related to Tibetan and
they use the same script as Tibetan but
they wanted to have a different identity
than tibetan for obvious reason so at
the same time at the 60s many people
spoke Hindi and there was a big decision
do you do we take Hindi as a other
language or do we take English and the
Serb King decided for English because of
international openings and he was
encouraged in that of course by the
famous Canadian priest Jesuit which was
behind the education
modern education moved father Maggie so
English became the official language of
Bhutan that's why you find people
speaking good English even in remote
areas and people speak 19 languages I'm
such a small in such a small country
people there are 19 language including
Nepali which is widely spoken because
they consider it very easily to learn
easy Torah and this is basically the
commercial language so indeed indeed
nepali are widely spoken in the south
and everybody speaks a smattering of
nepali so when people come to the
diocese and you can speak Nepali and
people love to speak Nepali because
somehow nepali has in Bhutan has a
lightness feeling to it
Nepali is a language of happy easy songs
movie so it's a it's a language which is
associated with very different things
than the traditional Bhutanese features
so people love to speak Nepali and many
of Nepalese who come to Bhutan surprised
how easy they can when they can speak
Nepali so easily
also in put out because origin Nepalese
origin population came mostly from
Darjeeling and Sikkim
the Nepalese is slightly different from
the kathmandu valley spoken apologies